Film Courage: What are some of the best ways
to become a better actor aside from being
a perpetual student in some of these classes
that I know are beneficial but you’re right,
people can get stuck in that, right?
Robin Riker, Actor/Author: And there is always
about classes, you want to be careful of teacher
as guru.
You really have to be watchful for that because
there are many times where it’s more about
the teacher and the student’s adulation
of that teacher than it is about the students,
you know?
So the way to become a better actor is to
act, is to get on stage as much as you possibly
can and don’t let any of this New York versus
Los Angeles theater thing dissuade you because
I’ve seen brilliant shows and stinkers in
big houses and small on both coasts.
So you just have to do it.
Actors act.
If you sit around your house and get a play
reading together with other actors that you
know just read (and then you celebrate afterwards),
you do that.
You have to do it because not and interacting
with other people is just social.
It’s very important I think and being a
not so absorbed person because you learned
things from every experience being out in
the world watching the way people move listening
to the sounds of their voices and the ticks
they have and the things they do.
It’s all about incorporating something real
into these fictional moments you are creating
on stage and the more reality you bring to
it the better you’ll be.
Here is a tip I’ve found valuable I learned
this very early on because my mother was actually
my coach and when I was doing Shakespeare
festival for two seasons when I was a kid
and she was getting her Master’s there at
Boulder.
So I had to audition for everything when she
wasn’t directing.
And I liked language so I had a proclivity
for verse.
But there were times when the verse…I mean
I was nine…so it didn’t fit in my mouth
quite right.
So what I learned was to put in my head…well
this doesn’t help with verse so much but
it helps with interpretation of anything and
in regular language this helps.
If there is a line that doesn’t fit in your
mouth well, rephrase that in your head the
way you would say that concept and then impose
that rhythm onto the sentence that you’re
given.
I wish I could have an example right now,
but if it’s something a simple as you know
“I want you to go to the store and buy some
celery” and that doesn’t make sense to
you, in your head you go “You know you need
celery?”
And then you go in your head “I want you
to go to the store and buy some celery.”
So you say it with the music of the rewrite
that you put in your head.
of the music that you put in your head, so
you impose the music of the rewrite on the
line that doesn’t fit in your mouth and
it really works!
Does that make sense to you?
Film Courage: Yeah, it sure does.
Because maybe it will be something that you
won’t normally say but you put it in your
voice.
I can’t really articulate it but I get it.
Robin: You put the music of your voice.
You don’t put it in your words.
You put it in the music that accompanies your
words.
So your superimposing the sound of “You
know?
We could use some celery.”
On “I want you to go to the store and get
some celery.”
Instead of “I want you to go to the store
and get some celery” (lowers her voice).
Or whatever, that’s a very silly example
but it’s the concept of the tone imposed
on the words that don’t fit in your mouth,
make the concept fit in your head and then
put the music of that over your words that
don’t fit.
Film Courage: Right, so if you say things
with maybe an inflection at the end, a question
or something or maybe it’s more of a directive,
whatever way you normally speak to someone
in that context you do it and try to fit that
sentence in?
Robin: The sound of that sentence over the
words that don’t fit because every actor
has gotten a line that “I would never say
this?”
And “Can’t make this real.
How do I make this real?”
So you reinterpret that sentence to your own
words and hear how that sounds in your head
and put the sound of that on the words that
don’t fit.
And it’s always worked for me and when I’ve
given it as advice to others they’ve said
“I like that, that really helps.”
Because it personalizes it, it makes it real
listening to the tones of others and that
sort of thing.
It’s very helpful.
So listen to your own tones too and have them
help you.